[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen sie haben
Teheran in ein Gefängnis verwandelt und
das Evin Gefängnis in eine Universität
singen die Demonstranten auf den Straßen
des Iran in der Tat gleich das
berüchtigte Evin-Gefängnis einer
Universität denn Irans Regierung hat
dort mittlerweile große Teile der
Kulturelite des Landes eingesperrt je
länger die Proteste dauern desto voller
wird es in hevin Feuer im Gefängnis war
gestern Abend die Nachricht die das
ganze Land und die Welt aufgeschreckt
hat und während die Welt noch abwägt ist
das jetzt eine Protestwelle im Iran oder
der Anfang einer Revolution zeigt die
Reaktion des Regimes wie sehr die
Mullahs fürchten dass ihnen die Lage und
die Macht entgleitet Kamera saffiarian
jetzt über das was wir aktuell gesichert
wissen
brennt es Schüsse im Innern des
Gefängnisses eine Augenzeugen filmt das
Feuer im berüchtigten ewinengefängnis in
Teheran gestern Abend
anderswo in den sozialen Netzwerken sind
Explosionen zu hören
mindestens vier Tote gibt es viele
Verletzte was wirklich passiert ist
lässt sich nicht unabhängig verifizieren
im Staatsfernsehen erklärt man das Feuer
sei von Meuterern in einer Schneiderei
gelegt worden um 2 Uhr nachts zeigt ein
Reporter eine hell erleuchtete
Gefängniszelle hier sei alles unter
Kontrolle die Insassen schlafen sagte er
einem Zusammenhang mit den Protesten
sitera nicht der Schriftsteller
dscheheltan wohnt in der Nähe des
Gefängnisses er glaubt an eine andere
theoriestände und Brandsätze von
regime-anhängern von außen in das
Gefängnis geworfen wurden es sollten
Insassen zu Tode kommen die dadurch
angeordnete Staatstrauer im Land sollte
dann weitere Proteste verhindern
die Lage bleibt unübersichtlich rasend
schnell einen protestierende und
Angehörige noch in der Nacht zum
Gefängnis
ein hubkonzert und wedelnde Kopftücher
als Zeichen der Solidarität
Tod ramene rufen Sie
denn in der Haftanstalt von Evin sitzen
neben politischen Häftlingen und
Künstlern auch Teilnehmer der
derzeitigen Unruhen und auch Ausländer
mit doppelter Staatsbürgerschaft
darunter deutsche das gefangene
misshandelt und gefoltert werden sollen
diese Bilder von Überwachungskameras
zeigen welche Bedeutung hat der
Gefängnisbrand für die Proteste im Iran
ich denke dass dieser Gefängnisbrand von
sehr hoher symbolischer Bedeutung ist
unabhängig davon wer ihn ausgelöst hat
denn er wirft ein Licht auf die
Situation politischer Gefangene ganz
normaler Demonstranten Jugendlicher im
Iran und deswegen denke ich ist es recht
wahrscheinlich dass er die Proteste eher
noch befeuern wird
auch in den letzten Tagen wieder
landesweite Proteste und Festnahmen in
vielen Städten Irans haben die Aufstände
Aussichten auf Erfolg fragen wir den
Schriftsteller
dieser Bewegung sind sehr groß denn sie
wird von allen Teilen der Bevölkerung
getragen die Proteste sind jetzt in eine
Phase der Revolution übergegangen vieles
erinnert mich an die letzten Monate des
Schah das Regime muss sich jetzt ergeben
und einem Referendum zustimmen wenn
nicht droht dem Land ein Bürgerkrieg
doch es sieht nicht danach aus dass das
Regime den Protesten so schnell
nachgeben wird Tehran heute ein
Gefängnisbrand und viele offene Fragen
Jörg Brase ist unser Iran Korrespondent
guten Abend Jörg nach Teheran was lässt
sich denn vor Ort recherchieren was ist
da passiert rund um das Gefängnis
also das ist wirklich schwer zu sagen
weil Aussatz zwei Reportern des
Staatsfernsehens niemand Zutritt zum
Gefängnis hatte und die
Sicherheitskräfte hatten gestern Abend
bereits aber auch heute den ganzen Tag
das Gefängnis weiträumig abgesperrt es
waren ja kurz nach Ausbruch des Brandes
schon Angehörige zum Evin Gefängnis
geheilt um zu schauen ob ihre
Angehörigen auch die im Gefängnis sitzen
betroffen sein könnten aber die
Sicherheitskräfte haben diese
Versammlung die sich da dann aufgebaut
hat relativ schnell auch mit Tränengas
zerstreut was genau da drin passiert ist
das wissen wir auch heute noch nicht und
deshalb kann man nur spekulieren was
jetzt tatsächlich die Gründe waren dass
dieses Feuer ausgebrochen ist offiziell
werden wie gesagt vier Tote bestätigt
und über 60 verletzte mehr wissen wir
zurzeit auch nicht
ja und dann vielleicht die Gretchenfrage
wie gefährlich werden denn die Proteste
die ja nicht enden seit vielen Wochen
jetzt für das Regime
also ganz interessant ist das Präsident
raisi sich gestern geäußert hat er
sprach davon dass man die kulturellen
Strukturen des Landes überprüfen müsste
im Zuge dessen müssen auch bestehende
Gesetze überprüft gegebenenfalls
überarbeitet und vielleicht sogar
aufgehoben werden das sieht nach Dialog
aus den er anbietet und der Druck auf
die Regierung scheint nach all diesen
Wochen des Protest tatsächlich groß zu
sein schon ältere umfragen sagen ja dass
über zwei Drittel rund 70 Prozent der
Frauen in Iran den Kopftuchzwang
ablehnen und das erklärt auch warum
Frauen aus allen Gesellschaftsschichten
hier protestieren auch das Vorgehen der
Sicherheitskräfte gegen die
Demonstranten und Demonstranten das löst
auch Kritik im Inneren aus das heißt die
Regierung steht da sicherlich unter
Druck und scheint jetzt
Dialogbereitschaft anzubieten und
insofern muss man auch sehen dass auch
diese Internet Zensur die wir da sehen
auch schade die Regierung hat
angekündigt dass jetzt aufheben zu
wollen denn jede Stunde der
internetsensur Zensur kostet die
iranische Wirtschaft Millionen also da
scheint sich im Moment ein bisschen
etwas zu bewegen Jörg Preise für uns in
Teheran Jörg vielen Dank
in der Politik bei uns in Deutschland
heute die große Frage wie geht es weiter
mit der Atomkraft und daran
angeschlossen die Frage wie geht es
weiter mit der ampelregierung beides ist
eng miteinander verbunden denn FDP und
Grüne letztere noch mal bestärkt und
gleichzeitig an die Leine gelegt von
ihrem parteitagern diesem Wochenende
haben dazu komplett unterschiedliche
Ideen Positionen und rote Linien Theo
guten Abend der Bundeskanzler irgendwo
dazwischen er hat heute in einem
Spitzengespräch im Kanzleramt nach einer
Lösung gesucht mit welchem Ergebnis
also ich glaube das einzige Ergebnis war
dass sich alle drei gegenseitig den
Sonntag vermiest haben man will sich
morgen und falls nötig auch am Dienstag
wieder treffen denn am Mittwoch müsste
die Lösung im Kabinett verabschiedet
werden und danach dann sehr schnell in
den Bundestag die nächste
parlamentswoche die ist erst wieder im
November das dürfte dann zu spät sein
denn das Atomausstiegsgesetz sieht ja
derzeit das Ende aller AKWs zum 31.12
vor wenn dieses Gesetz nicht rechtzeitig
geändert wird dann ist die ganze
Diskussion und der ganze Streit über
längere Laufzeiten überflüssig da sitzt
die FDP jetzt aktuell am kürzeren Hebel
ein Scheitern aber dürfte der ganzen
Ampel massiv Schaden wie könnte denn
Theo so ein Kompromiss überhaupt
aussehen wenn man sich die Positionen
anguckt dann ist der ja zunächst mal
wirklich schwer zu erkennen
also wie immer der Kompromiss aussieht
er dürfte nötig machen dass der Kanzler
seine ja gerne mal moderierende Rolle
verlässt und kraft Amtes und zur Not mit
Richtlinienkompetenz die Sache
entscheidet die Strategie von Olaf
Scholz des größte Schlacht getümmelt
erst einmal abzuwarten und dann die
ermatteten Streithähne irgendwie
zusammenzubringen die ist hier erkennbar
nicht aufgegangen denn jetzt haben sich
beide Seiten grüne wie FDP unnötig
eingemauert Parteitagsbeschlüsse wie der
der Grünen können von den Regierenden
zwar immer ignoriert werden aber so
zeitnah am Beschluss und so sehr die
Herzkammer der Grünen betreffend dürfte
das jetzt noch schwieriger werden als
das eh schon war und interessant in den
nächsten paar Tagen Theo herzlichen Dank
heute Abend
und Hannah du bleibst jetzt noch in der
deutschen Politik ja heute ist nämlich
der Bundesparteitag der Grünen zu Ende
gegangen unter anderem mit einer
hitzigen Debatte über die Klimapolitik
mit knapper Mehrheit stellten sich die
Delegierten hinter den von
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Harbeck
ausgehandelten Kohlekompromiss mit dem
Energiekonzern RWE dieser sieht den
längeren Betrieb von zwei rheinischen
Braunkohlekraftwerken bis 2024 vor was
auch die abwagerung des symbolträchtigen
Dorfes lützerath bedeutet im Gegenzug
wird der Kohleausstieg im Rheinischen
Revier um acht Jahre auf 2030 vorgezogen
zu Lage in der Ukraine dort meldet die
Regierung in Kiew unter anderem
russische Angriffe auf die Stadt nicopol
nahe dem Atomkraftwerk saporicia
Russland wirft der Ukraine seinerseits
den Beschuss der von Pro russischen
Separatisten kontrollierten Stadt und
jetzt vor Raketen hätten einen
Verwaltungsgebäude dort stark beschädigt
in Paris haben nach einem Aufruf linker
Parteien und Gewerkschaften 10.000
Menschen gegen die Sozial- und
Klimapolitik von Staatspräsident macron
protestiert die Demonstrierenden
forderten unter anderem Lohnerhöhungen
sowie Mehrgewicht für den Umweltschutz
in eines Streiks von raffineriepersonal
ist die Stimmung in Frankreich seit
Tagen angespannt an etwa einem Viertel
der Tankstellen im Land herrscht
Spritmangel
wegen des Pilotenstreiks bei der
Lufthansa-Tochter Eurowings streicht die
Airline in den kommenden drei Tagen fast
die Hälfte ihrer Flüge das hat der
Konzern mitgeteilt von 400 Euro Wings
Flügen würden am Montag 230 stattfinden
es ist der zweite Streik in weniger als
zwei Wochen zu dem die
gewerkschaftsvereinigung Cockpit
aufgerufen hat dabei geht es nicht um
höhere Gehälter sondern um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen
nie wieder das war die Lehre aus der
mao-herrschaft in China als geschätzt
bis zu 80 Millionen Menschen ums Leben
kamen weil der Diktator seine
Vorstellungen von Wirtschaftspolitik und
Gehorsam brutal durchsetzte nie wieder
mehr als zwei Amtszeiten für einen
Staats- und Parteichef nie wieder so
viel Macht für einen einzigen Menschen
das gilt nicht mehr Chinas aktueller
starker Mann wird nach dem Kongress der
Kommunistischen Partei der heute begann
so mächtig sein wie niemand vor ihm seid
malo hejing Ping der mächtigste Chinese
der wohl mächtigste Mann der Welt
Gebieter über 1,4 Milliarden Menschen
und eine Kaufkraft ohne die auch in
großen Teilen der deutschen Wirtschaft
die Lichter ausgingen insofern betrifft
uns das was gerade in Peking geschieht
ganz unmittelbar Miriam Steimer
die große Halle des Volkes kennt jeder
in China vom Geldschein heute ist sie
die Kulisse für die große
hijin-ping-show
alle fünf Jahre gibt es diesen
Parteikongress alles ist vorher
abgestimmt alle Posten schon vergeben
die Delegierten sollen nur noch abnicken
Statisten für hieß machte Demonstration
besonders großen Applaus erntet hier
beim Thema Taiwan er bekräftigt dass er
die Wiedervereinigung anstrebt wie er es
nennt zunächst friedlich
aber wir werden uns niemals dazu
verpflichten auf die Anwendung von
Gewalt zu verzichten
er will absolute Kontrolle über die
Partei über sein Volk über jedes Bild
selbst der T-Service ist eine
Choreographie
Ski feiert sich selbst für seine
null-kovit-politik während Millionen
Chinesinnen und Chinesen gerade im
Lockdown sitzen
wir haben darauf bestanden die Menschen
an die erste Stelle zu setzen und das
Leben über alles
Politikwissenschaftler Hut Young ist
einer der wenigen im Land die sich noch
trauen offen zu sprechen
in den letzten zweieinhalb Jahren ist
die Partei allmächtig geworden sie hat
das gesamte soziale und wirtschaftliche
Leben und unser tägliches Leben
übernommen sie hat jedem die
Reisefreiheit genommen alle Freiheiten
Ping hat die Pandemie genutzt um die
Überwachung massiv auszubauen sein
Werkzeug ist die corona-app ohne sie
geht nichts kein Einlass in Supermarkt
Bus oder Wohnkomplex Kontrolle bis in
den letzten Winkel des Privatlebens
unter dem Deckmantel des
Gesundheitsschutzes
he ist ein Machtmensch aber auch ein
Mann mit Mission
er ist offensichtlich wirklich davon
überzeugt und er ist durch das System
groß geworden dass es eine starke
Führung braucht um die Kommunistische
Partei und China jetzt im 21 Jahrhundert
zu führen auch wettbewerbsfähig zu
machen und er sieht sich als den Mann
dafür er hat die Begrenzung auf zwei
Amtszeiten abgeschafft und will weiter
Parteichef bleiben
sein Ziel findet sich auf der Rückseite
des Geldscheins hier will so mächtig
werden wie der Gründer der Volksrepublik
mau zu dong
nirgendwo wird man den Parteikongress so
genau und gleichzeitig so besorgt
verfolgen wie in Taiwan der Insel die
chijin Ping daran lässt er ja keinen
Zweifel gerne für sich hätte Nomen
Odenthal ist in der Hauptstadt Taipeh
guten Abend Norman auch heute hat hier
wir haben es gerade gesehen ja wieder
gedroht mit einem Militäreinsatz gegen
Taiwan worauf stellen sich denn die
Menschen dort ein
mir kommt es ein bisschen so vor wie mit
dem Taifun der gerade hier wieder mal
über Taiwan tobt die Leute sind relativ
entspannt relativ ruhig sie haben
offenbar gelernt sich mit der Gefahr zu
arrangieren wenn wir mit dem Menschen
über China heute sprechen dann sagen Sie
uns auch sie sind relativ entspannt und
die Töne die da aus Peking kommen die
kennen sie halt schon seit vielen Jahren
und Jahrzehnten also die Bedrohung
empfinden sie nicht als neu wenn man
etwas genauer hinhört etwas länger mit
ihnen spricht dann merkt man schon dass
trotzdem natürlich eine große Sorge da
ist und viele sagen uns in der Tat auch
sie halten einen Krieg für
wahrscheinlich früher oder später wann
der konnte ob der kommt dass sich
natürlich in den Händen Pekings was
macht Taiwan der Staat selbst rüstet auf
auch mit Hilfe der Amerikaner sehr
intensiv zum Beispiel wird auch gerade
darüber intensiv gesprochen die
Wehrpflicht noch einmal zu verlängern
zum Ende des Jahres hin könnte das schon
soweit sein auch der Taiwaner privat
bereitet sich vor so gut er kann es gibt
viele Leute wir haben sie getroffen die
an Kursen teilnehmen medizinischen
notfallkursen wo man zum Beispiel auch
lernen kann wie man verletzt auf einem
Schlachtfeld versorgen würde und viele
sagen uns das ist ihre Motivation warum
sie diese Kurse jetzt auch belegen viel
Zulauf haben übrigens auch militärische
Kurse bei denen man zum Beispiel auch
schon am Umgang mit der Waffe geschult
wird also was bleibt von diesem Tag
hänge ich denke so was wieder Eindruck
dass die Fronten sehr verhärtet sind
China poltert Taipeh Polter zurück und
wenn nicht mal die sprachliche
Annäherung zwischen beiden Seiten
gelingt dann stehen die Zeichen
vielleicht wirklich eher auf
Konfrontation zumindest früher oder
später Norman vielen Dank und alles Gute
mit dem Taifun
so und dann gucken wir auf das was wir
alle hier bei uns zu erwarten haben nach
diesem chinesischen Partei Kongress nico
huotari ist China Kenner er beschäftigt
sich beruflich mit nichts anderem als
Direktor des mercator-instituts für
China Studien Herr hohe Tore guten Abend
guten Abend in welche Richtung wird hi
der jetzt ja wohl auf Lebenszeit
regieren könnte denn sein Land führen
aus ihrer Sicht es ist erstmal eine
Bestätigung seines Kurses mit aller
Härte nach innen nach außen offensiv
Auftreten in der Wirtschaftspolitik
immer stärker den Staat in den
Vordergrund zu stellen also insgesamt
einen Kurs der auf Druck von innen und
auf Druck von außen reagiert und
versucht die Führung mit aller Kraft
nach vorne zu werfen sie sagen eine
Bestätigung seines Kurses schauen wir
uns noch mal kurz an wieder der Zustand
Chinas aktuell ist Immobilienkrise des
Wachstum stockt drakonische
kovid-lockdowns immer wieder wenn man
sich hieß Bilanz so anguckt sitzt er
denn dann wirklich fest im Sattel denn
von einem großart vollkommen ja wohl
nicht reden oder die Bilanz aus der
Sicht der Partei ist ist in der Tat
großartig sie feiert sie zumindest und
man darf nicht vergessen Ski hat viel
erreicht für die Partei hat den
Militärapparat reformiert er hat sich
durchgesetzt mit Blick auf die Frage ob
die Privatwirtschaft florieren kann da
ist er durchgegriffen er hat den
Sicherheitsapparat neu aufgestellt also
an vielen Stellen hat er sozusagen die
parteimission erfüllt dennoch ist es
klar die Wirtschaft
stockt es geht nicht gut die Kurve
Einschränkung sind weiterhin stark daran
schuld dass es wirklich in den nächsten
Monaten und Jahren für die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung nicht
besonders gut aussieht gäbe es denn
Menschen an entscheidenden Stellen in
Chinas Machtapparat die diesen
Personenkult rund um hier den wir gerade
auch heute noch mal sehr befremdlich
gesehen haben als Problem ansehen
als Problem mag das im Inneren durchaus
gesehen werden aber es gibt keine
Personengruppe keine einzelnen die an
der Stelle derzeit in der Lage wären
etwas daran zu ändern es gibt einen
ganzen Machtapparat der darauf
eingestellt ist sie den Ping hier im
Zentrum zu halten er ist der Kern der
Führung und das wird in den nächsten
Jahren sich grundsätzlich nicht ändern
was würden Sie denn jetzt einem
deutschen Unternehmen raten das abhängig
ist vom chinesischen Markt oder von
chinesischen zu liefern vorsicht es ist
wichtig die eigenen Abhängigkeiten der
genauen Blick zu behalten in der Tat wo
es möglich ist zu diversifizieren
natürlich gibt es weiterhin auch Chancen
im chinesischen Markt aber sie sind
durchaus unter dem Blickwinkel eben auch
der politischen Entwicklung in China zu
bewerten und diese neue Risikobewertung
ist das was jetzt eigentlich ansteht und
was heißt dann Vorsicht ganz genau was
sollen diese Unternehmen tun und wo es
möglich ist eben nicht alle Körper nicht
alle Eier in den gleichen Korb zu setzen
Diversifizierung sollte das Gebot der
Stunde sein an manchen Stellen
sicherlich auch die ein oder andere
Investitionen zu überdenken ist es denn
jetzt der richtige Schritt in einem
Markt der sich und eben noch stärker auf
Wettbewerb mit chinesischen
Staatsunternehmen einstellen muss da
dann sozusagen all in zu gehen dann
gucken wir noch auf die Politik in zwei
Wochen will Bundeskanzler Scholz zum
ersten Mal nach China fahren kann denn
das jetzt so weiterlaufen wie bisher
also mit starker Wirtschaftslenker
Delegation auf offener Bühne und dann
vielleicht ein paar kritischen Worten
hinter verschlossenen Türen
und das scheint der Pfad im Moment zu
sein Scholz hat eine große Aufgabe er
wird dort in Peking Signale senden
müssen die deutsche Interessen klar
vertreten er muss auch europäische
Interessen vertreten können und da geht
es auch darum sozusagen zu signalisieren
dass an vielen Stellen auch auf der
chinesischen Seite Bedingungen zu
erfüllen sind dafür dass es weiterhin
attraktives Land für deutsche und
europäische Investoren bleibt aber dass
man auch international bereit ist
weiterhin zusammenzuarbeiten Nico
huotari ganz herzlichen Dank für ihre
Expertise heute Abend bei uns vielen
Dank
das Gespräch haben war vor der Sendung
aufgezeichnet Hannah du guckst jetzt auf
eine Trauminsel in großen
Schwierigkeiten ja nach schweren
Überschwemmungen auf Kreta hat sich die
Opferzahl auf mindestens zwei Menschen
erhöht eine gestern noch als vermisst
geltende Frau wurde heute tot aus dem
Meer geborgen starke Herbststürme hatten
die Überschwemmungen ausgelöst und
massive Schäden verursacht der regional
Gouverneur von Kreta sprach vom
schlimmsten Unwetter seit 100 Jahren
zum Fußball da gab es in der ersten Liga
drei Begegnungen der erste fC Köln
gewann gegen den FC Augsburg 3:2 Union
Berlin spielte gegen Borussia Dortmund
entstand 2:0 und das Spiel des FC Bayern
München gegen den SC Freiburg endete 5:0
zum Schluss Sport der Bahnrad-WM in
Frankreich hat Lea Sophie Friedrich dem
deutschen Team ein weiteres Mal Gold
beschert die Titelverteidigerin
triumphierte am letzten Tag des Turniers
im kampfsprint Kain vor der Japanerin
Nina Salto und der Niederländerin Steffi
van der Viet für die 22-Jährige ist es
nach Gold im Teamsprint und Silber im
Sprint die dritte WM-Medaille
die größte internationale kulturmesse
der Welt wie sie sich selbst nennt darf
selbstverständlich royalen Glanz
erwarten Spaniens König Philippe und
Königin Letizia kommen nach Frankfurt
zur Buchmesse Spanien ist dieses Jahr
Ehrengast aber die Monarchen wie auch
alle übrigen Besucher kommen an einem
anderen Thema nicht vorbei das überhaupt
nicht glanzvoll ist wie umgehen mit
einem Krieg mitten in Europa der auch
den Buchmarkt betrifft zerstörte
Druckereien in der Ukraine kein Papier
wenig Leser da ist das gesammelte
intellektuelle gewissen der Welt
gefordert Christa Läpple hat sich
umgehört
wir werden gewinnen Serie shardans Hymne
für sein Land die Kräfte des Sieges ein
Song voller Hoffnung partus Verzweiflung
und Wut der ukrainische rockpoet ist
eine Art Campino seines Landes der
dokumentiert das Leiden seiner
belagerten Heimatstadt soeben erschienen
schadans Kriegstagebuch Himmel über
Racke
natürlich aber verstehst du ich bin kein
propagandistisch ich schreibe keine
Propaganda Literatur ja ich schreibe
darüber was ich selbst sehe also habe
ich keine Angst vor furchtbares
ist seit dem russischen Überfall als
freiwilliger Helfer im Einsatz er
verteilt transportiert und dokumentiert
nachts schreibt er seine erlebten
Geschichten auf zum Beispiel die vom 14
märz die Geschichte seiner Stammkneipe
in hakif mit dem Denkmal von Ernest
Hemingway
war ein Denkmal von Kevin mit mit dieser
und jetzt ist dieses zerstört und wir
können
seine Hemingway Kneipe ist ein
trümmhaufen
saschan der Krimis von krakev erhält für
sein Tagebuch den Friedenspreis des
Deutschen Buchhandels Frage gibt es
überhaupt noch Alternativen zum Krieg
nein sagt Irina schabakova
Mitbegründerin von Memorial der
aufgelösten Moskauer
Menschenrechtsorganisation seit August
lebt die russische
Friedensnobelpreisträgerin im deutschen
Exil das bedeutet
wenn das nicht passiert also kann man
diese Zukunft sich überhaupt nicht
vorstellen
tatsächlich macht jeder Kriegstag die
Ukraine starker so André kourkov laut
New York Times der bekannteste
Schriftsteller der Ukraine auch er kann
sich eine friedliche Lösung nicht mehr
vorstellen kurkow schreibt auf Russisch
denkt auf Ukrainisch jetzt ist für ihn
seine Muttersprache Russisch die Sprache
des Feindes es gibt ein Unterschied
zwischen Mentalitäten das ist sehr
wichtig die Russen sind Fatalisten sie
glauben sie können nichts ändern die
Ukrainer sind sicher sie können alles
ändern deshalb immer wenn die Ukraine
sind mit Politiker unzufrieden sie gehen
und organisieren ein neues Maidan
was kann Literatur in Kriegszeiten
bewirken nicht viel meint exerchattern
aber festhalten und beschreiben was
geschieht das sei wichtiger denn je
sind keine einfachen Zeiten was diese
Nachrichten Welt uns gerade zumutet ist
nicht leicht zu verarbeiten das geht
ihnen genauso wie uns hier auch
umso wichtiger ist das was jetzt kommt
der Beweis dass sich in der schlimmsten
Not auch das Beste im Menschen zeigt
dass wir zusammenhalten können und
plötzlich vieles geht was gerade noch
unmöglich schien meine Kollegin Alissa
jung hat so einen Moment eingefangen
diese Woche mitten in der Ukraine
das war Lidia pilypenkus Haus in
European ausgebrannt beim Angriff der
Russen im Frühling
wir haben dieses Haus mit unseren
eigenen Händen gebaut mein Mann und ich
Stein auf Stein
ihr Mann bekam kurz danach ein
Herzinfarkt hat diesen Schmerz nicht
überlebt doch Lidia ist nicht mehr
alleine der Garten an diesem Herbsttag
voller junger freiwilliger
schaut sie euch an sie sind wie Ameisen
so wirbelig und das macht meine Seele
froh
Ameisen die nicht nur Schutt in wenigen
Stunden beseitigen sondern auch Licht
und Leben hierher zurückbringen
district one heißt ihre Organisation
jüngere helfen älteren sammeln Spenden
für Sie und bauen ihre Häuser wieder auf
[Musik]
sah das schon dass du bald das kalte
Wetter kommt bald und wir haben gesehen
dass sogar lidias Fahrrad verbrannt ist
dank einem anonymen Spender konnten wir
ihr ein neues kaufen
dann haben wir Geld gesammelt und sind
mit einem Team freiwilliger
hierhergekommen
Lidia und Helferin Sophia sie waren
Fremde und sind sich jetzt ganz nah
roter
natürlich schaffst du das du bist ein
starker Soldat auch wenn du eine kleine
Frau bist aber stark in dir drin alles
wird wieder gut
ich weine nicht wegen diesem Desaster
ich weine wegen unserer kraftvollen und
schönen Juden
die Freiwilligen kommen aus allen Teilen
des Landes sind teilweise selbst
geflohen und helfen nun anderen sowie
Serie ich bin aus trasson hierher
gekommen ich wusste nicht wohin habe
erst in Odessa für eine Weile gelebt und
kam dann nach Kiew und habe bei district
one angefangen jetzt helfe ich jeden Tag
zum Schluss sagt Lidia noch mit unserer
Jugend muss man sich vor nichts fürchten
nicht vor Krieg oder irgendeiner
Katastrophe von nichts sie werden alles
aufräumen wieder aufbauen und alles wird
wieder schön werden
daran glaubt sie ganz fest
[Musik]
wirbelige Ameisen die sogar die Furcht
besiegen können zweieinhalb Minuten lang
der fernsehbeleg für Friedrich Schillers
großen Satz verbunden werden auch die
Schwachen mächtig
so jetzt gucken wir nach vorne in die
kommende Woche mit Annegret Oster
[Musik]
ab Dienstag wird sich Frankfurts
Oberbürgermeister Peter Feldmann wegen
des Vorwurfs der Korruption vor dem
Landgericht der Mainmetropole
verantworten müssen seine frühere
Lebensgefährtin soll als Leiterin einer
Kita zu viel Geld erhalten haben
außerdem wird Feldmann vorteilsname
vorgeworfen Anfang November wird in
einem Bürgerentscheid darüber abgestimmt
werden ob der 64-Jährige im Amt bleiben
darf
ebenfalls am Dienstag wird die
diesjährige Buchmesse in Frankfurt am
Main eröffnet erwartet werden sowohl
Bundespräsident Frank-Walter Steinmeier
als auch König Felipe ehrengastland ist
in diesem Jahr Spanien ebenfalls im
Fokus wird die Ukraine und ihre
Literatur stehen russische Verlage
werden auf der Messe nicht präsent sein
die Vereinten Nationen werden am Freitag
in Bonn ihren Bericht zu den
klimaschutzplänen der einzelnen Staaten
vorstellen der Bericht des Vorjahres war
ernüchternd ausgefallen er
prognostizierte zwischen den Jahren 2010
und 2030 statt der notwendigen
Reduzierung der Treibhausemissionen eine
Steigerung um 16%
unter dem Motto solidarische Herbst ruft
ein sozialbündnis am kommenden Samstag
zu bundesweiten Demonstrationen auf
gefordert werden weitere kurzfristig
wirksame Entlastungsmaßnahmen und
energiegeldzuschüsse außerdem die
Beendigung der Abhängigkeit von fossilen
Energien
und jetzt die Wetteraussichten morgen
kommen im Nordwesten dichte Wolken auf
ab dem Mittag sind dann regen und
einzelne Gewitter mit dabei in der
Südosthälfte ist es dagegen nach
Nebelauflösung länger sonnig 17 bis 26
Grad der Dienstag wird insgesamt
unbeständiger der Mittwoch meist trocken
aber schon kühler und auch danach geht
es wieder wechselhaft und kühl weiter
ja mit diesen ziemlich warmen Aussichten
schicken wir sie in eine neue Woche in
der sie hier Maria Slomka und Heinz Wolf
erwarten tschüss
[Musik]